[Music]
one path network
i mean you guys would have known who
they are already they do a fantastic job
in terms of disseminating
some of the most high quality dowel
videos on the internet in the english
language
they have now actually produced an app
now i know in this ramadan you're going
to want to take advantage of that
i've already taken advantage of that and
browse through the app and it's an
amazing app
i'm sure you're going to be downloading
it right now the link is in the
description
i think one of the most interesting
things to look at in terms of
when you talk about lgbtq rights and
america as a superpower
and also africa as a continent is
the approach of some of the african
presidents to
questions about homosexual rights so i'm
going to look at one
video today there's many of them online
of different
african presidents kind of answering
this in different ways one we're going
to look at today and then come back and
react to it
one of the major issues and it's a
holdover from sort of colonial victorian
is the issue of sexual preference
in many african countries in kenya to be
gay the lgbt
community is is illegal they just want
to have
equal rights the same privacy and
equality as all other kenyans do
is that something that you aspire to for
your country i want to be very clear
uh christian there is
i will not engage in a subject that is
of no
it's uh it is not of any major
importance to the people and the
republic of kenya this
is not an issue as you would want to put
it
of um human rights or this
this is an issue of society of
our own base as a culture as a people
regardless of which community you come
from
this is not acceptable this is not
agreeable this is not about uhuru
kenyatta saying
yes or no this is an issue that the
people of kenya themselves
who have bestowed upon themselves a
constitution
right after several years have clearly
stated
that this is not a subject that they
are willing to engage in it's very
you're going to get yourself into
trouble i mean for her to say you're
going to get yourself into trouble
to an elected official not just an
elected official but the president
of kenya the president of kenya i think
shows absolute audacity in fact i was
quite surprised
when i looked at the comments in this
particular video the one with the most
like 16 000 comments is one who is high
somebody is highlighting this point who
are you to tell he says
in the comment a democratically elected
leader
of a sovereign nation that he will get
in trouble for representing the values
of his people
and then he says correctly i think the
west needs to stop forcing minority
opinions down the throats of nations
that are fundamentally opposed
to those ideals let's continue listening
to it but it's a global issue right now
it's it's important to them
where they are why is it i am saying to
you as president
important to me as the leader
of 49 million kenyans
and after if you want to ask me my
personal opinion
what is your personal after i finish my
process i can talk about my personal
opinion
would you publicly say that people who
are lgbt
gay members of the kenyan population
should not be discriminated against
no kenyan should be abused
should be you know
mistreated in any particular every
kenyan
is protected by law you see here what
we're seeing is a clash
of uh we're seeing a clash of values
really but not just a clash of values or
in the sense that you've got these kind
of american
uh knowledge productions being forced
down
the kenyan president's and not just him
but the society in which he represents
because correctly he says
about ninety percent ninety-nine percent
some say nine out of ten
people in his country see homosexuality
as uh
inexcusable as an act but we're seeing
actual problems within the framework of
the westerner because
the western framework says okay you're
allowed to have a sovereign nation
and this is one of the um kind of human
rights that you can have
but at this end you can have a democrat
democratic vote but at the same time
you got these minority rights which you
should respect so what should be
prioritized here
should it be that you have democratic
agency of a for
of a sovereign nation that is
prioritized or the minority rights of
a group of people who have decided to
identify
through their sexuality so even within
the framework of western imperial
or ideology there's is a clash within
that framework not just
in contra distinction or juxtaposition
with the african nations
so let's continue and kind of finalize
with some thoughts
every single kenyan but
they also must recognize that their
freedoms
are also must be taken into the
entire context of the society and he is
right that is a question of society and
not only that but
on contractarian understandings of
liberalism okay where
you as as a subject individual subject
you are
contracted to the the foreign nation or
to the nation in question through
citizenship or whatever it may be
you are obliged to obey by laws you are
obliged to obey by law so now you have a
another layer
of problem not not once again a problem
between ideologies but within the
ideology of liberalism
because here we have okay sovereign
nation you have the democratic uh
initiative
and now you also have a third layer
which is a social contract all three are
pointing in the direction of
okay homosexual homosexuality can
legitimately from within theory
okay be seen as something which can be
outlawed but then that
the only kind of um thing against this
is to say well actually
homosexuals are minority right and that
should trump everything else
now you can make arguments either way
what i will say
is un inexcusable really is the fact
that in the past the uncle tom
the uncle tom barack obama when he went
to uh
kenya which is his actual you know kind
of mother
nation if you want to call it is actual
nation where it's from
he was speaking down to the kenyan
people most of which you don't believe
that homosexuality should be something
which is
practiced uh publicly or
actual penetrative homosexuality is done
he's speaking down and trying to lecture
them using western
uh imperial parliaments the point of the
matter is this
he went further in tying foreign aid
foreign aid with
whether or not countries
implement lgbtq policies this means to
say now look
when you have african countries in
poverty happening in african countries
and children
dying toddlers dying babies dying
because they don't have the food
to nourish themselves what what obama
and the
liberal project in america have decided
to do is say
that is less of a priority than
homosexuals
getting to experiment sexually in a
public sphere
can you imagine this so the right of a
homosexual
to have intercourse or to show intimacy
to his homosexual partner in a public
sphere because we're not talking about
what happens behind closed doors
that is more important
than the right of a child to eat and
drink
and we are gonna tie foreign aid with
your
uh with a foreign um prime minister or
president's ability to implement lgbtq
policies what have the kids got to do
with these policies
what a cruel and unusual kind of
punishment that you're inflicting upon
children who are completely bystanders
to these ideological discussions
it shows you the extent to which the
uncle tom
barack obama and those who follow his
footsteps are willing to go
to strip people away from their
rights young children democratic
citizens wherever you
whoever it may be in african countries
and this should
highlight to us the extent to which this
agenda this colonializing
imperial agenda of the americans is a
corrosive force
which needs to be tackled head-on
actually in the literature there is
there is a name
for this there's a name for prioritizing
kind of
one community right over another okay
and it's called homo nationalism
jasper poa says homo nationalism is
defined
as a facet of modernity and a historical
shift marked by the entrance of
some homosexual bodies as worthy of
protection by nation-states
a constitutive and fundamental um
relationship between the state
capitalism and sexuality
the point here is if you want what is
homo nationalism is basically
prioritizing one community in this case
the gays right gay community
whatever that may mean nowadays to be
honest because that is ill-defined
we don't know what that means no more
with with the inclusion of all these
other
letters of the lgbtq plus
over and above another community in this
case it's africans
it's black people it's children you see
who
can't get now the the the foreign aid
that they would have
uh used to feed themselves and to clothe
themselves
you